Well, if I'm traveling downstream, I can travel 8 miles per hour. And if I'm
traveling upstream, I can only go 2 miles per hour. Good work if you figured
these two out. One way to think about this is just by adding two vectors. We
know that I can travel at 5 miles per hour. And a current's going to help me
along. So, that's going to push me another 3 miles per hour. Now this only
happens when I travel downstream, I get pushed along by the current. So, my
total speed would be 8 miles per hour. But let's say I decide to swim upstream
instead. Notice that the current is going against me. We're moving in opposite
directions. This means that my rate of 5 miles per hour is slowed down by 3
miles per hour. So, I can only travel at 2 miles per hour.